hi guys this is route from simply lon
and welcome to this video where we'll be
telling you how you can install Java on
your Windows 10 operating system after
we're done with this installation and
also show you how you can run a very
simple program so now let's get started
so now let's download Java let's go to
Google and search for Java download
we'll go to the link we see here
oracle.com
so now here we have the web page here we
can see Java AC 13 so this is version 13
but this isn't the one we are going to
download we're going to download the
eighth version version 8 which is here
now we're doing this because 8 is one of
the more commonly used versions of Java
so let's click this and here we'll go
down we need to accept the License
Agreement before we can download it now
we have two versions here x86 and x64
now you can download it depending on
what version your operating system is
now if you do have a Windows 10
operating system it's highly likely you
have a 64-bit version of Windows now if
you do have a 32-bit version of Windows
you can take the x86 so let's download
this so you've actually already logged
in so we just need to run the installer
file now let's go go to downloads and
run the file so here we have the
Installer we go to the next step we will
select this too next here we can see
where the file is being installed to you
go to next now if you want to change
where you want to install Java we can
press the change option I'm just going
to keep it here we'll press next and
let's commence with installation and
there we go the installation is now
complete so we don't need any tutorials
or API documentation so we'll just
finish off and go to close now to see if
Java is installed in your system we can
go to command prompt and type the term
Java C which refers to the Java compiler
now as you can see here this shows a
number of different options you can
choose from this also indicates the Java
has been success
installed in your system now if the
installation was not successful you'll
see something like Java C is not
recognized as an internal or external
command operable program or batch file
but since we've done it successfully
this is what be shown now and now we're
going to set an environment variable now
what exactly is an environment variable
now assume you have a file which has a
dot Java extension this environment
variable tells the computer that the
Java program needs to be called to run
this particular file so to set the
environment variable we'll need to go to
control panel here go into system and
security go to system and select
advanced system settings and then this
shows up now before we go into
environment variables we will need to go
to where the Java file was installed so
let's go to this PC C Drive Program
Files and here let's go to Java so let's
go to jdk which is the java development
kit
let's go to bin here and copy this path
we'll go back to environment variables
select path here and then press on new
paste this and okay
now we'll go back and go to JRE to the
path of GRE which is Java Runtime
environment we click on this then again
and copy this path select this one new
and piece that and there we go the
environment variables are now set now
let's talk about running that simple
program I told you about now this is
possible with the help of an IDE and IDE
or integrated development environment
will give us a platform to code Java we
will be using Eclipse and IntelliJ as
they are popular and commonly used that
being said there are several other IDs
that are available in the market so now
let's work with eclipse let's go to
Google and search for Eclipse we'll go
to this link press download and then
this shows up let's click on download
now we've already downloaded the
software so I'm just going to directly
go into the install phase
notes and select clips with this you can
see that there are multiple options for
you to choose from so we're going to
select Eclipse IDE for Java developers
now you have other options like for C
and C++ JavaScript PHP and so on let's
go to the first one and here you have
the details you can change them if you
want but I'm just going to go ahead with
installation off you press accept now
here we remember accepted licenses and
press accept and then here as well we
will remember accepted certificates
select this one and accept selected and
there you go the installation is now
complete let's click on launch now so
here we are setting up a directory as a
workspace I'm not changing it here so
I'm just going to go with launch here we
have the Eclipse workspace now let's
close this first and here we have the
package Explorer now in case this
doesn't show up you can go to window
show view and select on package Explorer
so now let's go to file new and Java
project we need to set up a project name
I'm going to call it my project one go
to next we'll go to source so this is
where the source code for your program
is going to be stored then let's finish
and now we'll click on my project one go
to source I click new and create a class
within I'll name the class for my class
and create it and here we have it so now
let's write a simple program to multiply
two numbers so now let's write the main
function
open bracket now we're going to
initialize the first number now the
second one and finally the output and
finally the variable that will store the
output now we'll just give them a simple
print statement now let's run the code
by clicking this option here using my
cluster Java and there we have it here
the product is shown to be 100
indicating that the program is running
successfully now we're done with eclipse
now let's move on to the other IDE I was
talking about which is intelligent so
for that again we'll have to go back to
Google so that we can download it search
for intelligent unload go to this link
here so here you can see that we have
two options the Ultimate Edition and the
community version now here the ultimate
version has way more options as you can
see here but it's a paid version and
only has a free trial now the community
version is free so that's what we're
going to take so we'll click on download
here so I've already downloaded the
software so I don't need to do it again
so I'm going to go to downloads so here
we go let's just click on next select
the location where you want to install
it just next now we will add a 64-bit
launcher shortcut on the desktop and
create Association so basically this
means that these are the different file
extensions that this will support so dot
Java dot groovy and now let's go to the
next step we'll install now and we'll
wait and there we go the installation is
now complete
let's not import any settings we will
accept the privacy policy we'll set
defaults now let's create a new project
so here make sure your project SDK is
set to the version of Java you've
installed
make sure this isn't blank record next
here you need to select this option
which is the create project from
template and we are now going to create
a command line application press next
name the project which I'm going to call
my approach to you can change the
location if you want I'm just going to
keep it the way it is and then click on
finish so now we're going to create a
simple program through which based on
the users input we can determine whether
a number is even or odd its first we
could import the package scanner through
which we can take the users input next
let's go inside here let's create the
vailable reader now let's ask for the
users input we're taking in the value
now in the variable num leader dot next
int so this is with which we'll be
taking in the value from the user so
we're going to set up a condition to
determine whether the number is even or
not so if the number and when divided by
two provides the remainder zero it
indicates that it's an even number will
show them then
no for the ads case the number is not
evil or in this case odd there we go
we're done so let's run this program so
let's enter 12 the number is evil and
there we go we have a successful output
this indicates that the program is
running successfully and with that we've
also reached the end of this video I
hope you guys found this informative and
helpful thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simpler hi there if
you liked this video subscribe to the
simple learn YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos to nerd up
and get certified click here